[Música]
Estas son las noticias de France 24 en
Estados Unidos avanza el recuento de
votos de las elecciones de medio término
los republicanos están a siete escaños
de controlar la cámara de representantes
mientras que los demócratas aún solo
escaño de controlar el senado
en Perú solamente restan algunos
requisitos legales para que pase a
votación ante el pleno del Congreso el
proceso de inhabilitación del presidente
Pedro Castillo quien está acusado por
traición a la patria vamos a ampliar en
unos minutos desde la Ciudad de Lima
y cerca de 200 agentes de la policía
ucraniana ocuparon el centro de la
ciudad de gerson tras el repliegue de
las tropas rusas Mientras tanto Rusia
insiste en que el retiro de las tropas
no cambia el estatus de esta región que
fue anexada a la federación de Rusia
Hola muy buenas noches Bienvenidos a las
noticias de France 24 soy Santiago López
González Gracias por estar con nosotros
hasta ahora vamos a comenzar en el norte
de nuestro continente en Estados Unidos
en donde sigue la expectativa en este
país en donde avanza el recuento de los
votos de las recientes elecciones de
medio término mientras los republicanos
están a sólo siete escaños de tomar el
control de la cámara de representantes
el futuro del senado sigue siendo
impredecible ambos Campos ahora tienen
49 escaños la atención está centrada
entonces en el estado de Nevada que
todavía no ha oficializado sus
resultados y donde una victoria
demócrata daría al partido del
presidente Joe biden el control del
senado
los demócratas están muy cerca de lograr
mantener el control del senado cuatro
días después de la fecha oficial de la
elección Se confirmó la victoria de Mark
Kelly en el estado de Arizona resultó
reelecto y superó a republicano Blake
Masters Aliado del ex presidente Donald
Trump así las cosas ambos partidos
tienen ahora 49 escaños y ahora el
control de la cámara alta se juega en
dos estados claves Nevada y Georgia
Nevada todavía no pudo oficializar los
resultados allí es republicano Adam
tiene una muy estrecha ventaja sobre su
adversaria Katherine cortes más tú en
este estado sábado es el último día para
recibir votos por correo lo que explica
el retraso
pasemos todo lo que está en nuestras
manos para que las papeletas avancen lo
más rápido posible pero con los plazos
que tenemos no puedo terminar el conteo
hasta que lleguen todos los correos es
un número muy pequeño pero aún así no
puedo terminar antes del sábado
en caso de reelección para la candidata
demócrata el partido de Dubai del monte
tendría su control del senado con 50
escaños ya que el voto de desempate
recae sobre la vicepresidenta kamala
Harris pero en caso de Victoria
republicana Nevada el futuro del senado
se jugará nuevamente en el estado de
Georgia donde una segunda vuelta se
celebrará el 6 de diciembre entre el
demócrata Rafael Warner y ya no
republicano Walker se espera una feroz
batalla final con una avalanza de fondos
de campaña lejos de la marea roja
augurada por las encuestas los
republicanos están ahora a sólo siete
escaños de quedarse con una muy estrecha
mayoría en la cámara de representantes
y seguimos en Estados Unidos porque dos
aviones de guerra antiguos chocaron en
pleno vuelo durante un espectáculo aéreo
en un aeropuerto Ejecutivo en la ciudad
de Dallas en el estado de Texas les
advertimos que las imágenes que pueden
ver pueden medir su sensibilidad estos
destrozos que ustedes ven ahí de los
aviones pertenecen a los restos que
quedaron sobre una autopista las
autoridades locales indicaron que hubo
víctimas entre el público que estaba
presenciando este espectáculo pero no
dieron detalles sobre las tripulaciones
de ambos aviones ya comenzó una
investigación sobre este hecho
y en Perú hay reacciones tras la
aprobación de un informe que pide al
presidente Pedro Castillo para que sea
inhabilitado por cinco años y se le
acuse por el delito de traición a la
patria dicho proceso deberá cumplir
requisitos antes de su eventual votación
en el congreso peruano desde Lima
Francisco Zacarías nos da más
información en el siguiente reporte el
presidente Pedro Castillo ha sido citado
por el congreso de Perú el miércoles 16
de noviembre a una sesión de la comisión
permanente del parlamento para el debate
y votación de la denuncia constitucional
por traición a la patria en su contra
que fue aprobada por la subcomisión de
acusaciones constitucionales el
mandatario tendrá una hora para ejercer
su defensa si es que la comisión
permanente aprueba la denuncia se
convocará al pleno del congreso para una
sesión de debate y votación donde se
requieren 66 votos para inhabilitar a
Pedro Castillo Al respecto del
mandatario ha dicho que han inventado
denuncias y carpetas constitucionales en
su contra pero nunca tendrán corazón por
su parte la defensa del gobernante
rechaza el proceso porque afirma que el
congreso peruano no puede aplicar el
delito de traición a la patria cuando no
existe una sentencia de por medio contra
Pedro Castillo mientras que diversos
juristas sostienen que la denuncia no
tiene sustento legal porque jamás se
entregó territorio peruano a Bolivia y
la denuncia puede jugar a favor del
presidente Castillo para mostrar a la
misión de la oea de que existe la
convicción de la oposición para sacarlo
del Poder De cualquier forma los
incondicionales de Pedro Castillo
confían en que una acción de Amparo del
mandatario contra el congreso que fue
admitido a trámite Por una corte pueda
frenar la denuncia por traición a la
patria y una eventual tercera moción de
vacancia presidencial no muy lejos de
allí en Bolivia el presidente Luis Arce
mantuvo el censo poblacional para el
2024 lo que mantendría el registro
actual para las próximas elecciones la
oposición protesta en las calles de la
ciudad de Santa Cruz de la sierra ya que
piden que eso se ha renovado en el año
2023 de esta manera podrían disponer de
mayor cantidad de recursos públicos y
una mayor cantidad de diputados para los
comicios del 2025 el informes de lluis
Muñoz
la atención se mantienen las calles de
Santa Cruz mientras el gobierno
boliviano no da su brazo a torcer y
mantiene el censo poblacional y de
vivienda para el 23 de marzo de 2024 el
presidente Luis Arce hizo un llamado a
la calma las bolivianas y bolivianos
queremos vivir en paz somos de la
cultura del diálogo y de la paz y por
eso llamamos a pacificar entre todas y
todos
el viernes se cumplían tres semanas de
protestas es el plazo que dio la
oposición de Santa Cruz para convocar el
censo poblacional en 2023 Durante este
tiempo ha habido cuatro muertos y más de
100 heridos se acaben los resguardos a
los masitas se acaba en la violencia a
nuestra gente
y que estén con el pueblo que es lo que
Todos queremos el último censo se
realizó en 2012 el gobierno de Luis
arcelo retrasó de 2023 a 2024 alegando
el parón de la pandemia además de
bastión opositor Santa Cruz es la
segunda ciudad del país y el principal
centro económico es la mayor receptora
de migración interna por lo que el
aumento de población le otorgaría más
recursos de hacerse el censo en 2023 la
región tendría tres diputados más en la
asamblea para las elecciones de 2025 Sin
embargo esta protesta se limita a Santa
Cruz y no tiene apoyo en el resto del
país tampoco es un apoyo masivo de forma
interna Ya que el movimiento al
socialismo es el segundo partido más
apoyado en la región
no nos dejan circular no nos dejan pagar
No nos deja hacer nada Santa Cruz fue
también en 2019 el lugar desde donde se
ideó el derrocamiento del gobierno de
Evo Morales
vamos ahora con información de Europa
Hablamos ahora de las relaciones entre
Francia e Italia que están en un momento
tenso tras la decisión del gobierno de
la primera ministra italiana Georgia
meloni de no recibir un barco con
migrantes el Ocean viking que terminó
llegando a puertos franceses el gobierno
del presidente Manuel majó a
intensificado los controles fronterizos
entre ambos países para evitar entre
otras cosas el aumento del contrabando
cerca de las ciudades de mantón y
ventimiglia en la frontera Franco
italiana se intensifican los controles
los guardias fronterizos y la policía
están deteniendo a los coches
procedentes de Italia nos piden que
abramos el maletero y revisan nuestras
identificaciones las tensiones entre
Francia e Italia aumentan a causa del
Ocean un barco con 230 inmigrantes que
finalmente ha podido atracar en Tulum el
Ministerio del interior francés ha
desplegado 500 agentes más para ayudar a
realizar las inspecciones fronterizas en
la región el refuerzo de estos chequeos
implica mayores esperas para los
conductores
creo que Francia hace bien el limitar un
poco a todos estos inmigrantes que
vienen aquí y creo que cuando la policía
está aquí no puede estar allí hay otras
tareas más importantes para ellos que
permanecer en un puesto fronterizo
Los contrabandistas también son buscados
en estos controles desde principios de
años se ha detenido a 680 de ellos a
pesar de la posibilidad de cinco años de
cárcel y 300.000 euros de multas y son
detenidos su número va en aumento
Los contrabandistas pueden ser guías en
los senderos pueden ser personas que van
a buscar en vehículos privados pero
también pueden ser robos en camiones de
transporte
otro foco la estación de tren de
mantonga gabán
el tren de cercanías que viene de Italia
espera 15 minutos más
tarjeta de identidad pasaporte por favor
el retraso molesta algunos pasajeros
estoy en contra de este tipo de control
dificulta la libre circulación los
automovilistas y pasajeros de tren que
se dirigen a la frontera tendrán que
acostumbrarse a esperas más largas ya
que se prevé que la situación no cambia
en los próximos días tras La retirada de
las tropas rusas avanza la retoma
ucraniana de la ciudad de gerson en la
jornada de hoy unos 200 policías
ingresaron a esta ciudad y volvieron a
emitir las estaciones de radio y de la
televisión ucraniana entre tanto en el
kremlin insisten en que el retiro de las
tropas No cambia nada el estatus de la
región que fue anexada de manera
unilateral a Rusia
la celebración de una reconquista El
regreso del ejército ucraniano a la
ciudad de personas ha sido catalogado
como la mayor victoria de kiev desde que
inició la invasión hace ocho meses Rusia
dijo que retiró a más de 30.000
militares de la urbe hacia la otra
orilla del río niepera
los ciudadanos esperaron nunca
repudiaron a Ucrania tenían razón al
depositar sus esperanzas en Ucrania y
Ucrania siempre devuelve las suyas me
alegra ver a esa gente a pesar de todos
los peligros la represión y el
sufrimiento infligido por los ocupantes
que se aferran a las banderas ucranianas
en el centro de kiev cientos se
reunieron el viernes por la noche para
celebrar la noticia muchos son
originarios de gerson pero que huyeron
cuando las fuerzas rusas los invadieron
en marzo
Ginger son muchos empiezan a regresar a
sus hogares o lo que queda de ellos los
rusos destruyeron y saquearon casas pero
no todo se fueron como esta granjera que
recuerdan los angustiosos momentos que
vivió durante la ocupación
no el camino
nos van con las culatas de los rifles
los rusos dañaron las casas de los que
sirvieron a su ejército y se llevaron
los bienes de las mejores casas
gerson fue la única gran ciudad
ucraniana en caer en manos enemigas
Rusia sigue controlando alrededor del
60% de la región que lleva el mismo
nombre incluida la costa del mar de azul
y que fue anexionada ilegalmente junto a
otras tres por Moscú el principal punto
de acceso a la ciudad cruzando el río
nieper era el puente Anthony Sky ahora
destruido según lo confirmado por
imágenes satelitales imágenes que
también señalan nuevos daños en La
Represa de novakahovka al norte de
gerson y cuya eventual voladura
generaría desastrosas inundaciones en el
país
el famoso artista británico vansky
reveló estar detrás de una obra pintada
sobre un muro en un edificio destruido
en Ucrania en el obblasta de kiev y no
sería la única pieza de los alrededores
pero de momento el artista no lo ha
confirmado veamos
quizás no laven muy bien seguramente
porque lujo está atraído por los
escombros Pero hay una gimnasta en
equilibrio sobre el muro de este
edificio bombardeado en las afueras de
kiev un símbolo de la resiliencia y la
resistencia que recuerda un famoso
artista pero del cual nadie ha visto la
cara banksy
es el símbolo de que somos
inquebrantables y que nuestro país es
inquebrantable y a pesar de que esté
destruido lo vamos a reconstruir y todo
irá bien pero lo esencial es que somos
libres y podemos hacer de nuestro país
un lugar mejor pase lo que pase
desde hace varios días los rumores sobre
esta obra abundan en la red y fue
precisamente en Instagram donde el
artista británico reveló ser el autor en
el título solo se especifica la ciudad
borollanca
fue uno de los primeros lugares en ser
bombardeados al comienzo de la guerra
también aquí es donde se descubrieron
obras similares especialmente esta pelea
de YouTube donde un niño derriba un
adulto encontramos el mismo toque el
mismo compromiso pero aún no se tiene
confirmación por parte del artista para
mí es increíble que banksy esté aquí en
Borja
este pequeño niño contra un hombre
adulto y que lo derrota y es así que
está pasando
no muy lejos de aquí en Irving también
se descubrieron otros dibujos queda por
ver si el artista se revelara no es la
primera vez que banksy se aventura en
terrenos de guerra para entregar un poco
de poesía en medio de los escombros esto
en las noticias Punto Final siga con
nosotros
[Música]